the government's clearest roadmap yet to
restoring some form of normalcy in
America President Trump has laid out the
guidelines for gradually reopening the
country starting as soon as today in
some states with a goal of balancing the
economy while keeping people safe but
there are concerns that a lack of
widespread testing makes it very
difficult to truly control this crisis
Anthony more than 22 million Americans
have filed for unemployment since
mid-march including more than 5 million
just last week the nationwide death toll
has soared past 33,000 the future of
tens of millions of people could depend
on the decisions made in the days ahead
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
what do we know about these guidelines
good morning Anthony yesterday President
Trump told state governors that they
will be calling the shots on
implementing this new staggered approach
to reopen the country that is a reversal
of his comments earlier this week where
he said he had total authority to reopen
the states but this approach gives cover
to local leaders who want to get back to
business while also shielding the White
House from blame if there are new
outbreaks America wants to be open and
Americans want to be open president
Trump Thursday announced new federal
guidelines for reopening parts of the
country based on the latest data our
team of experts now agrees that we can
begin the next front in our war which we
are calling opening up America again it
is a three-phase approach that should
only begin after a state sees a two-week
decline in coronavirus cases and
encourages a robust testing program for
health care workers in phase 1
individuals and businesses will still be
advised to maintain social distancing
while they gradually return to work
large venues will also be able to open
if they can maintain strict physical
distancing we did not put a timeline on
any of the phases we want the governor's
with the data that they have community
by community to be setting up those
timelines if states are able to go two
weeks without a rebound of cases they
to face two venues including restaurants
theaters sports arenas and places of
worship could operate under moderate
social distancing schools and organized
youth activities could also reopen
through all phases continuing the good
hygiene practices continuing their
respect for spaces between individuals
because we know that we still have an
issue with a symptomatic spread as for
who decides when to move through the
phases just days after saying he had
absolute authority to reopen the country
the president back down we're
recommending certain things they'll be
in place dependent on what the governor
wants to do dr. Anthony Fauci cautioned
that states need to have enough testing
and medical equipment to respond to a
possible resurgence the flexibility is
that there may be some setbacks I mean
let's face it this this is uncharted
water there may be some setbacks that we
may have to pull back a little there are
multiple check points of safety there
you can call it whatever you want but
even if you are in phase 1 2 3 it's not
ok game over local officials and
business leaders say more testing is
needed before they can safely reopen but
this plan does not provide a national
testing strategy instead it leaves local
leaders to develop and implement their
own testing plan Gail
Thank You Paula